les phrases cultes voilà c'est ça ce
qu'on veut revoir c'est tout ce qui
était dedans les phrases cultes hamel
tout le monde tous des victimes
ouais je sais pas si ils apprécient
faire l'amour au temps des mammouths ont
bouffé le must c'est faire l'amour en
bout quand tu vois la vie privée en fait
vite or vous laisse à l'intérieur je
viens à la galanterie super tout brega
qu'ils attendent c'est une vision
tellement tombé sur le meilleur canadien
de loi moi j'ai moi j'ai senti là la
grosse merde on a senti le meilleur
toujours moi toujours tué par le chien
ou le playboy tout mais toujours
toujours toujours moi une sorte d'être
enceinte pour avoir les pêches est
peut-être temps charbon situation et
nous éviterons que c'est pas normal
qu'on ait dit que loana serait sûrement
qui sort la gueule alors à toi de dormir
à dire rien d'essayer de l'aider et le
puits par mois
franchement moins montré quoi c'est
pourquoi
les pilotes maison des secrets est ce
que vous savez pourquoi y avait des
poules oui poule 2 pour les oeufs et des
poules les poules n'ont as tu sais ma
vie parfois c'était un peu limite
justement les poules c revenait à faire
des plans quand justement la situation
instable et peu limité activement aux
états unis je te laisse ça aux états
unis celle là c'était un aquarium et là
à partir de la saison 2 s'il y avait un
petit décalage mais là comme s'était du
direct pur non et bad et que tout d'un
coup il pouvait se passer quelque chose
d'un peu sexuelle ou un peu ont focalisé
sur les poux et lentes et pourtant
regardez des poules
les accus père est absolument lé putsch
et michel mais surtout qu'ils ont fait
ça juste après la scène de la piscine en
avant la scène de la piscine n'avait pas
ce pôle emploi et bien sûr maggiore doit
on l'a vite et jean-edouard il n'a pas
voulu dire bon souvenir pourtant kamel
qu'avait dit oui mais il peut pas se
contenter aux camélias ville habite plus
à paris meba très bien il voulait faire
un one man ont su 24 elle me l'a pas
fait mais il va très très bien et kamel
et les célèbres pour une phrase laquelle
les horaires ilim le fameux team le team
mais vous êtes revue déjà tous les deux
ou pas du tout arrête toi oui
enseignants dans les lâches
la première fabrique vous êtes sortis de
la mer va pas de bus qui sont rentrés
ont nourri nos soirées pendant ces six
mois on s'est vus pendant sa
garde à vue et après banon qu'est ce que
vous vous dites mon retour de mario
premier regard
non mais
s'accroît massacré pas imaginer et donc
effectivement kamel célèbre pour le team
s'équivaut du team
18 ans
abbas a fait don il est où ta mère
d'éric ingrat c'était la saison à un
double culture elle est est ce que vous
savez de sandro
landreau
6 1 la gagnante est la gagnante de la
saison 2 en effet à l'annoncé pas la
gagnante passé c'est carrie marine soit
tenté par une semaine ces cabanes
delgado a new way pour une mauvaise
nouvelle je crois familiale c'est ça
c'est ça mais toi tu es resté
commerçants ont dû partir et ça au bout
de onze mois et demi un mois et demi
lenteur j'étais ouais tu va nous
raconter qu'une seule semaine oui
comment donc comment ça se fait qu'on se
souvient tous de toi comme ça
mais il barnils à bien son groupe
célèbre barney
j'attendais
ne va grandir
[Musique]
à millions d'exemplaires sauvage quand
même j'avais été maligne parce que vous
êtes une chanter tout le temps dans le
loft ouais phil barney la vue puis quand
est sorti on a eu l'idée de faire ce
petit comme le dirait maintenant en
ligne un featuring futuring phil barney
alors juste avant toqué mangue et on
était sûr sandra la fameuse ch'tis dans
l'offre on essaie d'intervenir mais je
la cherche même pour des documentaires
et tout ça vous chercher beaucoup de
monde gervinho est à vis de ces malades
on est des cochons truffiers dans ma
boîte de prod on cherche des gens d'un
peu partout ont fini par les trouver je
t'aurais sandra lévénez vous tord
[Applaudissements]
s'arrêter kwajalein temps le plan et la
partie
c'est pas moi moi je fais cuisine c'est
fou quand même à un kenza et kate était
là
c'était le un bon alors kenza qui a eu
une petite histoire avec jean michel
maire
gisèle et parce qu'il l'avait annoncé
quand j'ai on était ensemble annoncé ce
jour là et pas sérieux risques avec
cyril et on parlait de tout et tout d'un
coup il dit j'ai eu une aventure avec
quelqu'un d'ici ben ouais avec
jean-michel
la loi une aventure avec jean-michel ça
c'est la base toi ça mais
si l'on avait comblé mission la main
vous souvenez de jeu tomates avec un
droit à
cette aide a dit david
thébault david un très beau david oui
mais david qui tient une kadir sur david
ben oui parce que je les rencontre est
ouvert il ya quelques jours tenait la
petite virée à côté de chez moi
il fait des pizzas italiennes délicieux
c'est dans le hot suresnes pour se
connecter à côté c'est moctar au ciel
les deux bombes qu'on va voir là
qu'avait dit je t'emmerde avec un grand
a et le message qui s'adresse aux lois
sur l
île et accidents les lois sur l île
vient alors à l'italien ait tiens
énormément des points il fait venir du
moins en italie etc c'est un super resto
et j'ai découvert ça moi je le trouve
hyper sympa j'ai découvert c'était le
david du loft ya quelques jours regardez
triplé de vie un peu mais bon déjà je te
coupe moi déjà je tire mon chapeau
d'être là mais car j'imagine le rapport
à sa famille les anglais
avec un grand a
ils
étaient superbes aux aurait bien mérité
bouquin en
souviens quand même
assez enfin ce n'est pas du tout ça je
dirais pas bongo selon olé beau gosse
mathieu on
nous confond des souvent oui j'avoue que
j'ai pas de pizzerias l'on ne trouve pas
au delà
enfin bon on n'a pas été
noir lui céder le bail avec les beaux
gosses c'est mieux maintenant chevaux et
même maintenant toi oui c'est vrai ouais
je prends mais en plus je préfère mais
kamel parvenu salariés toujours été
revanche oui car elle n'a pas bougé car
elle n'est pas bougé voilà qu'à mais n'a
pas bougé alors on a fait les secrets du
loft et là vous avez pas envie d laurent
s'est dit secret du loft alors petit 1
vous direz c'est vrai ou pas les
employés de tf1 avait interdiction de
regarder l'émission c'est vrai ça alors
déjà c'était sur m6 non les employés de
tf1 avait interdiction de regarder
l'émission sur sur m6 mais il a regardé
tous mais il a regardé tous les vents
mais apparemment c'est quoi
pourquoi parce que tout simplement parce
que tu es là il y avait vraiment une
bière guerre entre les 2 50% de parts de
marché donc effectivement donc et une
sorte de frustration et pour éviter que
les gens soient frustrés et surtout que
les gens leur en parle tout le temps
baïse éviter justement d'être connecté
mais ils l'étaient tous connectés mais
en parler peut on vous en parlait pas
céret 500 films et 24 heures ça va aussi
par exactement il y avait en face le
bigdil commencé à chuter les écrans
publicitaires soit passé de 14000 à
50000 euros le spot publicitaire qui
animait
si vous saviez sachets n'a alors le cas
tout vous dire si c'est vrai et tout
aussi marlène pour le casting le casteur
devait prétexté un coup de téléphone et
sortir de la pièce en vous donnant pour
seule consigne de vous laisser carte
blanche face à la caméra c'est vrai ça
ou pas ils l'ont fait avec vous pas
sur le téléphone sonne il te laisses tu
vois il sortait de la pièce il te
laisser seule demande et non ils n'ont
pas fait
il ne faisait pas ça faisait quoi non
alors ce qu'il faisait en général c'est
m'étais face à la caméra ils disent par
son marlène c'était plus le même cas
pour le loft terrain tu regarde la
caméra et la caméra est un bonhomme que
tu doit séduire et brest est bon on a
une compil justement va regarder ça il
est candidat matane où alain croiseront
la 113 adore charles en fait je chantais
le temps
j'ai tant cacher
différence en général quand il ya un
garçon qui me plaît et le saas est assez
rapidement
trouver enfin la personne
que je pense je suis pas quelqu'un de
points c'est quoi je veux pas
je suis pas quelqu'un qui va à qui
vendre la première car son iphone par
exemple j'aime d'ailleurs
[Applaudissements]
qu'est-ce que tu avais dit du coup tu
avait séduit la caméra ouais québécois
et j'ai dit que c'était un garçon il
fallait le séduire but avait dit quoi
j'ai dit
ce que j'avais 20 ans j'étais insouciant
basse et ça donne en retrait de 20 ans
ou s'ils rentrent gâteau c'est d'arriver
ancienne coiffeuse marlène ne travaille
pas beaucoup quand elle n'est pas avec
ses amis elle retrouve sa famille qui
suit de près ses aventures amoureuses
c'est comme ma copine c'est vraiment
plus que tu crois je raconte tout tous
mes des tous mes bas
sexuelle tout tout tout
[Musique]
vous avez pris en flagrant délire vous
êtes rentrée voit bien garçons et non
les armes et plus des trois ans s'éclate
quoi
[Applaudissements]
ça sonne j'ouvre y aperçoit un porte
bonheur
était bien comme ça ex coiffeuse
c'était leur idée bien oui moi je j'ai
suivi il avait 20 ans j'avais pas
c'était nouveau voilà c'est une super
expérience en tout cas je regrette pas
c'était super expérience grâce à ça j'ai
pu chanter avec phil barney on a vu un
million et aujourd'hui grâce au loft je
suis là où je suis je suis très heureux
alors vous êtes tous eh ben j'ai pu
faire tout j'ai pu après le loft on a
fait un million d emplois épargnés
ensuite on a continué dans la musique
j'ai créé ma marque de lingerie et
ouvert des instituts de beauté j'ai pu
investir dans l'immobilier
je savais pas tout le temps voilà donc
tout ça grâce au loft si vous avez vous
à voir ce qu'il a fait lui mais là c'est
il a des restos dans tout paris paul
biya qui lassés de gaitan d'affaires
délaisser nos revers dans son resto abah
abah déjà tu as well connais tout ou ccc
grattant c'est un tueur à levallois
levallois lui a glissé le gars est un
truc à bien qu'elle dit et lui a valu
n'y a pas eu les balkany lui même un
calice un peu en dessous excusons un
bracelet je veux une
enseigne comme troisième secret donc 4e
pardon benjamin avait des indications de
la production pendant les prime pour
orienter les votes c'est vrai que ça
allait quand même s'inquiète ses portes
la les votes étaient pas du tout c'est
un sport lente et oui avec sa croix du
livret a va sortir parce que je suis
sorti voilà je devais pas sortir je vais
continuer aventure au milieu mais cette
fois qu'elles ont été abordés ouais pour
des raisons de avec la presse on
s'entendait très bien je supportais plus
et du coup ils ont attendu que les votes
continue qui l'ont fait appeler des
cadets des casernes de pompiers pour
être puisque à l'époque il fallait voter
et dès que je suis passé le dernier
alors arrêtez arrêtez donc c'est pas du
trucage parce que wii fit constate bien
et puisque moi je voulais partager
fallait trouver mais légalement il
fallait que j'arrive dernier on pourra
sortir ce que veut être piqués aux gens
c'est que allez donc pas truc à l'époque
souvent ses 51 49 51 49 est arrêtée
quand tu voulais après la classe tarral
il ya eu des règlements ici crète où il
y avait un horaire où ça s'arrêtait et à
cette heure là précisément c'est à
partir donc voila sinon je peux dire que
ma gilbert dehors elles peuvent être à
ce prime
magalie vaé qu'ils essaient de sortir
tout le temps à chaque fois que ça
passait devant ou derrière c'était pas
le bonheur il pouvait pas l'enlever oui
non mais pour en revenir à la télé
réalité et au vote enfin le public il
aiguillé depuis que depuis la nuit des
temps a ajouté l'arrêté même pour moi
j'ai su à l'époque où j'ai gagné quand
j'étais un petit peu en bas dans les
sondages de culture fr voulait me voir
gagner ils ont mis énormément d'image of
mind de la victoire où je pleurais où je
pleurais du coup les jeunes et zodiac
pour petit bonhomme et observe montée
ils n'ont pas pipé les votes parce que
c'était vraiment les sms mais du coup
avec les ans à dire que la télé trichet
non ils ont
la zotac que l'on doit la semaine passée
papy c'est carrément de la triche
puisque cinéma j'ai joué sur l'émotion
des gens non mais n'a pas donné sa
réponse était sûre et certaine celle où
il vient donc les gens qui vous rappeler
que c'est un souhait voilà on n'y peut
rien oui mais ça allait avec lui parce
qu'il sera télé parce que je devais
sortir je voulais y ait des gens qui ont
appelé pour rien oui oui je pourrais me
gausser
j'explique paul et nous ne leur est pas
mais les gens ils ont payé pour rien
alors
que les gels à le percer dans cette les
stars il souhaitait sortir des premiers
prime et il est resté plusieurs prime en
souhaitant que les gens ne votent plus
pour lui mais les gens continuent à
voter pour lui donc effectivement il ya
des candidats effectivement qui sonne
très positif pour la production après
les sénateurs qui sont d'accord c'est un
accord accord alors est ce que c'est
vrai ça mais je pense que c'est étonnant
que de 1,6 en une qui avait steveen à
prêter aux toilettes pendant toute la
première semaine parce que des caméras
dans les toilettes alors oui c'est vrai
mais dans la 2nde aussi avait des
caméras sécurité mais non c'est normal
alors l'explication elle est là
l'explication les simples il y avait
donc une caméra la production le rallye
17 caméras ne vous filme pas c'est pour
deux raisons la première raison ce n'est
pas un problème de santé une deuxième
raison est moins drôle si vous décidez
de vous suicider en est où absolument et
troisième raison si vous avez
l'intention également de vous droguez
tourner la caméra faut bien que
quelqu'un derrière long mais elles
filment en permanence et à dire que
l'accès qu'il est sur l'étoile est donc
effectivement on voit tout et donc et
bien quelqu'un qui regarde parce que
sinon et si la personne se suicide un
bras par dial et daniel est conçu et
mais les anglais bande quelqu'un qui
suit si tu regardes deux heures après
beaucoup maigri pendant l'émission on
pense qu'elle fait vomir dont conserver
de surveiller effectivement c'est par
une semaine n'est pas les belges
aujourd'hui c'est un peu il est avec les
poules il finissait avec les poules
ça te dérange pas il paraît que ça
existe encore mais dans tout était
l'héritier encore les toilettes de leur
analyse nous avons joué au foot et voilà
c'est pas ça c'est qu'on le savait pas
réellement c'est à dire c'est que tu les
vois pas si tu sais c'est qu'on est
rentré le mois jaune ses souvenirs on
oublie les caméras on l'attend on parle
à quand je fais caca m'a tuer puis des
caméras là bas c'est encore pire c'était
a besoin de vacances on avait des potes
ou qu'ils étaient filmés la première
fois tu les vois bouger mais comme t'as
pas dû merde pour toi c'est les caméras
de surveillance et donc tu les oublies
surtout au début de surtout un débit et
surtout qu'on était novice on sait plus
de caméras de surveillance ont été
arrêtés aujourd'hui dans les dix jeux
cia et par les deux chaînes de télé
réalité comme tous les ans les douches
au stade que dans deux pleins de pays
dans mes en hollande eux mêmes en grèce
et ça existe encore big brother c'est
encore ça fait des dizaines d'années que
la saison 2 il ya eu là 3 après c'est un
petit peu ces
dernières
aux états unis dont 100 la 23e saison
bah oui c'est moi c'est nous c'est sympa
c'est une institution
samedi soir non mais c'est vrai qu'après
le secret story qui se voulait la même
chose sa tenue quasiment 15 la même
mécanique que loft aoula les gens
étaient vraiment pur
nous
aussi alors quand même comme tanger pur
pur c'est que vous connaissiez un petit
peu de mécanique agricole mais aussi
d'aller vers
l'avant quand tu rentres pour une
première saison je suis désolé mon ami
sanctuary pour une première saison
la production était un petit peu dirigé
et s'est tué pur tu sais pas ce qui va
t'arriver écoute c'est pas justement ça
va être l'explosion de leurs les deux
mois qu'ils sont venus chercher on avait
on avait entendu parler du phénomène
assure son agent je te prends temps mois
calme tu vois le portrait que j'ai je
veux dire si j'avais dû calculer tout
j'ai pas dit non mais j'ai pas premium
et s'il n'était pas plus fort mais quoi
qu'il en soit ces noms vous connaissez
rien quand tu rentres tu arrives c'est
comme moi quand j'allais sur ce plateau
je connais pas je découvre effectivement
c'est une belle découverte met par
ailleurs bien sûr et surtout déborah est
par ailleurs
c'est la chef est pareil et pas et par
ailleurs effectivement il était beaucoup
plus pur non peut pas leur enlever cette
qualité il était beaucoup plus simple
ensuite c'était quand même un peu des
profits des fois c'est changer faire
regarde téléspectateurs c'est nous qui
avons fait que l'accès mission irez vous
savez quand même petit scoop que dans
d'autres pays pour l'instant c'est en
train de revenir le loft et notamment
avec des personnalités des gens connus
qui réunissent comme ça pour être et
c'est étudié en france c'est sa droite
restant
fermés vous pourrez venir un génial
mais le phénomène a pris de surprise
tout le monde mais même si vous pensez
que ça allait faire un énorme succès ont
été surpris de l'impact indépendamment
des ordures qui ont été déversées devant
m6 et les vitres cassées et u 13
millions d'articles publiés à ce moment
là et les gens d'être sauvé l'homme s'y
attende ont en général il détestait et
ça a été vraiment une manne financière
très intéressant pour m6 puisque ça leur
a quand même coûté à l'époque c'est
quand même pas rien 70 millions de
francs et ça leur a rapporté 170
millions de francs c'est quand même à
l'arrivée d'ailleurs c'était tellement
détesté que au début aucun animateur de
m6 ne voulait l'animé d'actes marie aube
et animateur de tf1 non plus chez pas si
vous en contact et à l'époque on pas du
tout
non mais ce qu'ils ratent
aucun animateur de tf1 aurait quitté la
chaîne a dû attendre pour aller profiter
des raisons sanitaires déjà coulé
en fait il est tellement pas d'animateur
qui voulait il ya eu sabatier y en avait
plein de carole rousseau et personne ne
voulait danser une merde américaine sa
fondue en mordre les doigts donc ils ont
été prendre un pauvre chroniqueurs
des célébrités ils ont amené lui les
verts rien à perdre et c'est comme ça
que ça a changé
mettez vingt pages et la lune noire pour
dire pourquoi elle ne faut pas regarder
le loft veut quoi parce qu'il voulait
quand même surfer sur le succès ouais
mais avait des choses à 6 sur le la pour
dire une gentillesse urbain juin il
était très bien dans ce programme ont t
ils étaient complètement raccord celle
ci vient découvrir et surtout il était
très bon et moi je l'aï interviewé pour
les 20 ans du loft et il m'a dit un truc
assez intéressant surtout oui tout ce
tous les animateurs qui ont refusé à
l'époque était un peu d'aidé tête
d'affiche dans leur domaine et c'est la
plupart ont disparu aujourd'hui et louis
est lui par contre continuer d'avoir une
carrière de l'été dans une piscine hier
avec bernès est vrai
pardon mais mais le loft nouvelle star
cyclades story c'est pas mal hein sûr
mais vous l'avez bien là on veut bien la
callas je l'apprends demain 6e secrète
où les lofteurs on signe à un contrat ça
faisait bien si c'est vrai que ça lui
sinon stipulant qu'ils devraient
reverser 70 % de tous leurs bénéfices
après la sortie du loft dédicaces
booking boîte de nuit à la société de
production donc à l'époque donc ils
devaient le rester 30 % seulement c'est
vrai ça pas vous êtes signer un contrat
alors y avait ça mais moi j'ai resigné
où je pense que tu étais sûr qu on a mis
le doigt dessus ben non je ne sais pas
alors c'est pas exactement ça c'est à
dire comme nous ont fait connaître il
allait gagner argent pour se récupérer
l'argent quand tu signes un artiste tu
as surtout en 360 tout le monde tous les
producteurs font ça ils ont voulu faire
ça j'ai eu la chance d'avoir on avait le
1 des messes des avocats très bon sur
paris et casey les contrats chaque fois
on a cassé contrat que j'ai pu moi
sortir un partenariat avec m6 et la
chanson et j'ai gardé tous les droits
tout le monde droits d'image et voilà
donc aux éditions paquet question à
l'époque vous n'étiez pas payés à la
journée à travers ses ppp hier un email
on a vu ça
collaboration on avait un contrat au
colorado
ils arriveront expliquez-moi laurent
queyssi je vous dis ma mine francs par
donc si je vous dis boubou va bien alors
bon va bien vous va bien sitôt
l'astv c'était sa petite peluche qui
était véritablement bourrique oui c'est
quoi un code c'est
aller exactement il était dans le loft
il vivait tous ensemble il n'avait
aucune idée de ce qui se passe et
extérieure est ce que c'était des stars
pas des stars ils entendaient juge
décrit à peu près lors des prime à
travers un mur il savait pas et la
première fois que quelqu'un est sorti il
ya peu au bout de quelques personnes et
sony va trouver un code si quand tu sors
tu vois qu'on est énorme star tu dit la
phrase boubou va bien effectivement si
on revoit les images stevie est arrivé
il a été interviewé par
kenza pardon c'était kenza et à lady
blue va bien et donc depuis plus aucun
sortant n'a été interviewé en sortant de
l'émission sympa habite là-bas voilà ce
qui permettait juste de rajouter sur le
loft 1 effectivement c'était les mêmes
contrats 70% pour la production
effectivement dès qu'ils sortaient les
booking etc ils ont tous refusé ils ont
attaqués avec des avocats ils ont gagné
ensuite ils ont fait leur booking eux
mêmes puisque en général à booker quand
ils vous arrivent oh oui vous ils vous
place il prend dix à quinze accusés vous
peur nous on y va
c'est autre chose alors lors de la sa
sacrée vite le soir de la première du
loft l'agent ce qui ce qui est public a
vu toutes ces réservations annulées à
cause de la mauvaise presse faite à
l'émission de l'époque ça ce que te me
dire c'est vrai ça ouais à l'époque à
tout le monde qui a tout annulé alors
ils ont dû vous savez la fameuse scène
où ils sont tous en train de les
accueillir les lofteurs et leurs valises
ils ont dû demander à tous les
techniciens mais non de venir et de
faire semblant de faire une sorte de
pont gris qui accueille tout le monde
comme ça en hurlant
c'est tout un problème des mollahs si
vous les regardez maintenant il faut
tout seul
c'est un bureau
j'aime ce qu'ils ont essayé de cloner
les candidats de la première en partie
et donc du coup je me souviens la vision
c'est le record absolu d'audience là
évidemment si on de la deuxième
évidemment mais on retient pas tout le
monde non non non bien sûr on était onze
millions merci
la 2e 11 millions pour aider parce que
tu es deuxième single chez sortie
tranquille
tranquille emile ouais quand le petit il
est émis tu connais
[Rires]
je vais tenir tranquille dans le loft et
on va sortir tranquillement battre
tranquillement cet art la grande chine
et mine la production servait des apéros
trésor aux lofteurs pour qu'ils se
lâchent entre le soir c'est vrai ça ou
pas d'alcool marlène de référence et du
nec a fait rentrer durée car pour caen
sera le plus demandé on avait
très peu de sucre est aussi vous avez
pas du tout parce qu'en fait l'om qui se
passait c'est que ils ont fait la
première expérience en servant de
l'alcool pour un peu débridé un peu tous
ces candidats mais nuit s'est avéré qu
après le lendemain il serait plus du
coup la production n'avait plus d'image
donc à mon époque on avait droit à deux
bouteilles de champagne par soir on
était vain donc ça fait très très peu et
donc beaucoup le lendemain parce que je
fasse on n'avait pas de gueule de bois
c'est l'alcool la première il
surveillait beaucoup il se remet tout on
pouvait pas rentrés effectivement avec
de la course
qu'on
sait pas ce que c'est
rené chiffres et les missions
extrêmement surveillés ils ne rentraient
pas avec est alors qu elle était
beaucoup plus contrôler aussi sur le
2-2 et des courses et donc on a besoin
de choisir de la bouffe de l'alcool
monde en prenait feu de l histoire de
fêter c'est vrai dire un mot comme sur
la la promo de chacun aujourd'hui la tnt
quoi et bien c'est un mot que j'ai pas
de fiche d'accord j'ai ouvert des
instituts de beauté bien-être bien-être
j'ai créé ma mère de produits de beauté
d'accord j'ai ma marque de lingerie
aussi et ben voilà et le reste que
j'avais fait un petit tour en tout
cas mal pour mon ça quand même et toi
tu attention si on y va parfois j'ai un
livre toi tu as un livre qui est sorti
la garosse ouais mais aussi d'une
collection qui s'appelle toute une
histoire et je retrouve sur le sport que
j'adapte en télé après en terre est bien
en concert à lille chante concert à lyon
fait les zéniths tous les zénith avec
michael avec d'autre part moi c'est ça
tout le moins leur guise et on part en
fait avec m6 ont pas de venir et ça ça
déraillait dont il ya eu michael un ring
mois charlie lui donc au
génial en bas pour s'éclater etc les
restaurants du tapas et le slogan c'est
le sud-ouest à paris des quotas pages
issues des cas on a tous bien le
rappeler